when you mentioned the mexican mafia it
reminded me of some stuff that i saw on
the news not long ago
where like the mexican mafia was upset
with somebody made the movie was it uh
american history x or something like
that and you stepped in and calmed
everybody down
it was uh american me american me yeah
yeah
american history x was backwards this
guy was
was
a racist and then he goes into prison
and he becomes a non-racist it's the
other way around you go into prison
non-racist you come out
racist
yeah that's just what it is and a lot of
the trouble that we have out here with
racism it stems from prison
um okay because that's because when they
go in they have to stick with their own
race and then like you kind of just get
indoctrinated
go with the wrong one and you're in
trouble
right and so like did i did i read that
right in the news that like that you
like smoothed everything over with the
mexican mafia and this movie guy
there's a there's a documentary uh
mundo
one of the mexican mafia guys
did a documentary i forget what it's on
but he says danny trejo is blessed he
walks on both sides and that was a hell
of a compliment coming from
enforcer of the mafia but but uh
but uh
it talks all about
edward james made some serious mistakes
man you know you don't
i would rather have a mangy dog for a
friend than an enemy all right and and
he
just really disrespected some people
that were still alive and some people
that were that passed away that had good
reputations when they were alive so he
got in a lot of trouble so
he won't admit it but yeah i saved his
life
man i mean did that i remember because
it just jogged my memory i was i
remember thinking dude
danny trejo
just
[ __ ]
cleaning up some messes with some real
heavy hitters some [ __ ] scary [ __ ] i
thought man danny's for real
one of the guys that told me because i
got
i i was doing a movie called bloody
blood out
which was taylor hackford
and i got offered a part in american me
by edward james
and uh
me and eddie bunker went and talked to
him and his manager over at uh what's
that name of that restaurant on ventura
boulevard
uh there's casa vega
true of no no there's two of them it's a
it's a like a jewish deli
enchanters
no it's on ventura boulevard
damn it
it might be not trejos tacos
bowling alley on ventura and by vineland
and there's another one
what
jerry's deli come on
okay
and we went and we met him and his
manager there and i didn't like it from
the start because he showed up
wearing like a
a county jail shirt
and and county pants looking like in a
headband looking like you know a cholo
from east l.a i'm telling you hey hey
we're encino [ __ ] with you know the
hell you do on you and i you know he's
one of those guys that has to stay in
character you know and
and uh
and those guys
they bugged me because if you're playing
a killer how do you stay in character
that's fantastic
so so uh
but so we talked and it was like we
asked him hey did you uh did you clear
this with joe morgan joe morgan was like
the leader
at the time you know the mexican mafia
and yeah yeah yeah we did we did
and that was a red flag right there you
know me and eddie both looked at each
other we knew he had because joe morgan
we knew
you know and we knew that there's some
things in this strip that he would never
approve so
okay so anyway we left and then uh
and then that afternoon
i got a call from joe morgan well i got
a call from my cousin sal who was in the
county jail and joe morgan had come down
from folsom and
and they said uh
my cousin called says hey danny
do you know joe morgan yeah i know or
are you okay are you in trouble because
joe doesn't call anybody unless it's
we're gonna kill you or
uh you know
did you get the stuff it's like so
i said no no i don't know why what's up
oh he wants you to go over to eddie's at
five
because he's gonna call you
so okay
so
you get a call from it's not a good you
you understand
right we all have that friend like
getting called into the principal's
office and and so he i go to eddie's
eddie answers to him hey yeah he's right
here
what's up big joe you know what's up hey
danny uh i understand you're up for that
movie uh american me he found i had just
gone
show you
their pipeline i had just met him at
jerry's deli
that morning
i got
i was at eddie's getting a call from him
at five geez now he's locked up
and uh yeah what i hear you up for that
movie
yeah well i'm up for both of them
which one was what are you gonna do i
said i'm gonna do bloody and blood out
oh yeah that's the cute one i'll never
forget that because that's the cute one
it's all about murder prison gangs
yeah
he said yeah you know what because it'll
be a lot of trouble with that other one
that guy said he'd come up here if he
didn't visit me i refused to see him
shows oh i'm glad i didn't do it wow so
on prison movies dude like in your
consulting do you guys have to sign off
with like the the shot callers to see if
it's okay to like do certain things no
we don't have to because we know what's
right and what's not
you know if they're gonna disrespect
somebody that's alive or somebody that's
dead that you know
wait a minute
i i remember when they were doing they
were doing a movie in venice and they
had a
they were wanting to use venice 13 this
line and i remember i was i was driving
by and i stopped
and and i waited a minute there's a
movie set and i just stopped i said what
are you guys doing you see this well uh
well you because we're
you can't use that holmes that's
that's a real gang
you want
them you're gonna
really oh blue then it's 15 good
you're eight more jesus
and so so basically
bloody blood out and american me were
the same subject matter but one was la
onda which was my gang the other one was
the mexican mafia
that's a real gang
you understand so even though they were
about the same thing this one was
fiction this one wasn't
you know eddie would have been better to
do a documentary
does honda mean the wave
the oh the the way it was the way it was
and the problem with the american me the
main problem was that one of the
characters was raped in prison was that
what it was
rigged in juvenile hall
yeah
and then that was a and that was a real
person that they're
and it didn't it didn't happen
and then and then it said that the
mexican mafia killed cheyenne they
didn't the northern faction killed him
you know so it was basically
edward didn't understand see that's the
problem with guys that have never been
on the streets writing a documentary
about the streets it said wait a minute
it's like
i remember saying this is not
facts
and him saying theatrically
it really works i said you're not
dealing with theatrical people
yeah do you understand these guys will
kill you
this is the most fascinating yeah this
is this is i can't even understand that
this is so fascinating can i just tell
you how [ __ ] up my new tour is it's
completely multimedia legitimately
x-rated there's legal waivers all over
the venue because i'm actually worried
about getting sued and i don't give a
[ __ ] man because it's gnarly and it's
all the stuff i wasn't allowed to do on
jackass so get to my [ __ ] website
stevo.com and get your tickets man
especially with this movie coming out
dude they're all going to sell dude so
hurry up while you can get seats